[Music]
hey
ladies and gentlemen what's going on out
there today yeah
man last
night knew you're gonna start with that
for tom we'll talk about it later
well yeah i told him i said you know
it's like we haven't watched a movie
movie like i said would you watch the
guard documentary so we could probably
talk about that but it's like um we'll
probably this is probably going to be
like a matinee sidetracks hybrid i'm
thinking because then we need to talk
about other [ __ ] although i kind of feel
like all of our matt knows matt nations
are really a sidetracks hybrid but at
least i'm being honest about it this
time you saw that new guard documentary
it's pretty good it's on shutter yeah
i think it came out at fantastic fest
like for like last year like at the
thing but i don't know where else you
can get it i don't know if it's like it
says shutter exclusive on it so i
imagine that it's only on shutter for um
for a limited time and then it'll go to
other streaming services but
this was a surprisingly i'm not like um
i like guar but i'm not like a massive
like guar fan or anything i'm like
i saw them like a bunch of times like
back in the back in the day like back in
the 90s
and um you know it's not well the thing
about guar is that it's not so much
their music like some of their music is
good but it's like it's mostly just for
the show and like the experience
um so we used to me and my brother and
like some of our other friends used to
go all the time
so i saw him a bunch of times but like i
said i'm not a super fan
but even though this documentary it's
like it's long it's like two and a half
hours or something like that
but i it was never boring i was like i
thought it was like really really
interesting i just really really liked
all of the
mo i mean it's mostly like interviews
with the founders of it and like you
know members old and new and like
they're just kind of talked about like
their roots and where they came from and
so it's kind of less about their music
and more about like the personalities
behind it and like i said it was
actually like as it got toward the end
because i think i mentioned this on the
side on the friday sidetrack show but
you know a couple of the members died uh
one of them got shot he survived but um
you know talk about that a little bit
but
you know it's so it was almost kind of
like touching and like sad at the end
and now that like some of the members
are getting older like are in their 50s
and stuff you know it's like one of them
got cancer and like so it was kind of
getting sad toward the end but
i don't die off
well yeah well and the thing about it is
that the ones that died like dave brocky
who was actually like one of the guy one
of the two guys that founded it um he
died well he was 50 i think that was
back in 2014 and he died of a heroin
overdose yeah
and then um the other guy that died what
was his name corey something he was like
one that had joined like later
and he just died i can't even remember
what he died of he just died like on the
tour bus like he died in his sleep
and he was pretty young too i think but
i don't remember i don't i think drugs
was implied probably
probably but one of the guys um one of
the guys when they were out on tour and
they were all in a car like they got
essentially like carjacked yeah and
and one of them got shot yeah and they
thought he was gonna die like he got you
know it was bad and he was like bleeding
and [ __ ] and then like the cops came and
they got into the hospital and he lived
thankfully and he's like okay now but he
said that for a long time when they were
touring he had to wear a colostomy bag
because they had to take a bunch of his
colon out yeah like i guess he didn't
have to wear it like um permanently but
i was like you would think it being guar
that they would use the colostomy bag
like in the act but at least they didn't
want to go that far they don't want to
go like they don't want to go like gigi
allen likes uh because they're like
we'll just keep with the fake blood and
semen and stuff we don't want like real
[ __ ] like somebody getting [ __ ]
diseases and all that other kind of crap
but uh yeah but i recommend it it's it's
an entertaining watch uh i didn't know
much about war
uh when i was in detroit um
right after i graduated from high school
if we went back to michigan to go hang
out with my friends and [ __ ] ended up
in detroit but uh
i saw some black and white repedograph
posters of them around town like they
were gonna play and just these [ __ ]
crazy dudes and [ __ ] weird barbarian
costumes that must have been
about 88
87 88 yeah because i think that was
right around when they first i mean i
think it was like mid to late 80s that
they were first kind of starting out
yeah and like they go into that and i
actually didn't know a lot about their
origins i guess
um so that was actually really really
interesting it was just kind of like all
these art school kids yeah
and musicians they were musicians but
they were mostly art school kids that's
what they were most yeah they were all
into like comics and lowbrow art and
stuff like at a time when it wasn't
really that cool to be into that kind of
stuff yeah um so they're actually they
were actually from richmond virginia
yeah and they said that there was this
old abandoned factory in richmond that
was called it was the dairy ready like
it used to be a dairy bottling plant or
something and they said it was abandoned
and like all of so all these artists and
hippies and [ __ ] like that like started
squatting there and so they said that
was kind of the place that all the
musicians and artists and stuff they all
had their like performance space and
practice space and everything you
weren't technically legally supposed to
be living there but like everybody sort
of did
so that's kind of like where the origin
of guar was because you had um
the one guy that had the band death
piggy which was kind of like a punk band
and then the other guy who was making
like a sci-fi film and building all
these
weird costumes like about like these
intergalactic warriors and stuff and
they were barbarians yeah like
barbarians and the barbarians yeah and
so they decided hey why don't we like
collaborate well i think the initial
thing was that death piggy was gonna
play a gig locally and they said
wouldn't it be funny if we dressed up in
these barbarian costumes and opened for
ourselves
like so
and they just said they just made up a
[ __ ] band yeah it's called war well
yeah well actually it was called guar
it was like with all these other letters
at the end
and then they said so they did that a
couple of times and then they noticed
that everybody was coming to see that
band instead of death picky like to see
their costumes and stuff and all the
crazy [ __ ] they would do so they said
well let's just make that like a real
pant yeah make that our band that's it
that's make that our band so yeah and
like obviously as time went on like they
got better yeah costumes like they
actually got like dudes that were like
professionals
yeah what was cool though is that they
had some old old footage of what they
were like in the early days and how
house when they didn't hardly have any
money well they never really had much
money all right um yeah they didn't they
lived off of very little they they spent
everything on [ __ ] costumes and
artwork that they were making for the
[ __ ]
and um
i showed kind of how advanced it was
even in the late eight even in the late
80s when they were new like they were
having a damn concert outside and they
had
a [ __ ] huge 747 jet engine on a wire
come from one big from top of one
building down behind the stage it would
crash on the ground and it was just it
made a paper mache but it it looked cool
looked like a jet engine that was that
was how the show ended there's a [ __ ]
chat
[ __ ] it hits the ground you know this
was pre donnie darko yeah
yeah and uh you know [ __ ] they're
just talking about destroying america
and
they're alien barbarians the scum dogs
of the universe and just you know
kind of a cool concept and they and i
mean they got in trouble a lot too
obviously because of their stage shows i
mean they would decapitate people like
in real but and i think what they got in
trouble for to adapt real people no no
yeah like fake people obviously like
obviously fake people they were like big
paper mache people i think what they got
in trouble because one of them got
arrested and was in north carolina right
i think it was north carolina
somewhere in the south uh they got
arrested it was either because
was it because they were doing that
where they had like the priest that they
were like sticking the
priest being raped by some demons a
crucifix or something like sticking it
up his butt yeah like but it was a big
huge like fake butt it's a fake butt
it's a dude with a fake butt
it's like it's obvious it was an awesome
costume it was actually he wasn't just a
priest i think he was like a demon
priest who had been married or something
yeah they had a whole story about him
yeah and and uh so everybody gets
punished uh whoever whoever's unpopular
at the time you know they were because
it was kind of just current events then
they would do it well the cops saw that
and arrested them but it was thrown out
of court the [ __ ] chorus like what no
it was good i don't think anything
happened well yeah i don't know if they
well see that's the thing i don't
remember if it was if it was the
crucifix in the butt or
was it remember how he used to wear the
the cuttlefish of cthulhu which was like
a dick which is a dick but it's actually
like a fish and then it just like
sprayed something that looked like semen
but it's not really semen obviously but
it's like out of its mouth
and so i thought maybe they got in
trouble for that because it was like
obscenity but then the funny thing about
that was like when they had to go to
trial
uh they said the j the presiding judge's
name was dick boner yeah and they're
like yeah
does anybody see the irony of that that
like you guys got upset about it's like
it's they're like it's not even a dick
it's a fish it's like an alien fish yeah
that like sprays and but somehow but you
know north carolina i ain't get much
trouble though
no i don't think they don't think they
went to jail or anything but i think
they did actually have to go to go to
trial they were just uh
harassing them trying to get him to stop
that [ __ ] and that was back when people
cared i guess
nobody would give a [ __ ] today
probably not like i said everybody be
like yeah but yeah
well i mean yeah but back in the like
the late 80s and early 90s it was like
kind of a big deal i mean they were like
would go around on all the talk shows
and everybody's like talking about and
moral panic going on it was satanic yeah
like because the satanic panic was still
going on like in the 90s i don't know if
you guys remember but so that was that
whole thing and
i think the thing about
gwar and like i said it's i don't even
think nowadays there aren't any original
members because one of them died and
like one of them left and he was on
there like talking and stuff but
um but they kind of like would rotate
people out like as people left it was
not so much a band as just like a big
art collective you know what i mean they
would just kind of like bring in artists
or other musicians and you would kind of
either come up with your own character
or you could take over like one of the
other characters you know what i mean
like it's just like oh we need a new
balzac the jaws of death and we need a
new beefcake the mighty or whatever and
like you could come in and do that or
you could like um come up with your own
and then you had to have like a whole
backstory because their mythology is
like really really complicated
like this but that was like their whole
deal and i think that was the thing that
struck me the most about how cool this
documentary was is that these were just
a bunch of guys and a handful of of
women too
that
this was just all they wanted to do they
just wanted to build these crazy
costumes and make comic books and do all
these art installations and do all these
crazy shows and come up with all this
wacky [ __ ] and they did it for like
they've done it's almost like 40 years
that band's been going now yeah and they
just they're so into it and honestly
in the 90s i think they kind of got real
fame they they were underground famous
like i had seen them like i said a few
times in the late 80s but i kind of feel
like they got more mainstream famous in
the 90s because they were on a bunch of
talk shows and like because they were on
beavis and butthead because they were
like beavis and butthead's favorite band
and they were in the beavis and butthead
video game and all this other kind of
stuff so that kind of like brought them
to a much wider audience and so they
because there was so much controversy
about them it was like oh my god i got
to see this [ __ ] and i think they were
in that movie mystery date too
so you know and they so they were kind
of known as that
so but i kind of feel like what happened
after that was that because they got
such a big audience around then
um
a major record label i think it was
warner brothers like wanted to sign them
because they were on metal blade at that
time
yeah
warner brothers wanted to sign them but
the album that they had
the i mean the lyrics were just like so
raunchy i think what warner brothers
objected to was one of the songs was
called baby dick [ __ ]
yeah
like you know what i mean and uh warner
brothers was like yeah we're not doing
that like they're like we'll put the
album out if you take that song off yeah
and they said no yeah and actually metal
blade stuck up stuck up for him and said
yeah we're not taking that dog off yeah
so warner brothers was like bye
so i mean they never got rich off of it
but like i said you could tell just
from the interview because they
interviewed a [ __ ] ton of people that
were in guar at some point or another
and they were just all really into this
i mean they were just having the [ __ ]
best time yeah i think i think you know
dressing up in these costumes and having
these alter egos on stage is really just
the main motivation for them being in in
the band they didn't make any money
no not really
and they would [ __ ]
that one dude said
he had the most money he'd ever had in
his whole life when he left gwar
got a job and then uh then i think he
went back to it eventually didn't he
yeah yeah a lot of people did like they
would leave for a time and then like
come back because like i said it was
always kind of like a rotating more like
an art collective so like if you had to
go do something like somebody else could
take over your character or a new
character would come in couldn't see
them and they would yeah so it didn't
really matter so they would just kind of
like write around like the mythology
because like i said they have a really
complicated mythology i think i think
they actually stuck with
for a long time
all of their songs having to do with
their sort of overarching mythology of
them being like like you said
intergalactic sort of yeah uh you know
the aliens that were like coming here to
like destroy earth or whatever
some of their fan
base too because they stopped they they
did a period where they went away from
rock and started to do other kind of
stuff well it started getting a little
bit movies and with characters and like
uh like sleazy p martini although i do
like that character yeah that's a good
character he's supposed to be the
manager i think yeah yeah with that big
huge [ __ ] hand yeah yeah that should
have his that's
but there was egomaniacs in there you
know what i mean they
thought there were too many characters
stealing the limelight and there was all
kinds of they were they were fighting
all the time
yeah particularly like the two guys that
founded it and i think for a time too
because they started out like pretty
much as a as a thrash metal band
and then punk rock and punk rock too but
like i said it started out as a punk
band and then they just like went but
they started going a little metal
and then um but then like it started
getting they said it started getting
like goofier and goofier like we weren't
really like focusing so much on like the
punk or the metal anymore yeah like it
started getting goofy and they like were
doing all kind of different styles they
didn't really have any focus anymore
one of the early lineups of the original
lineup or the near original lineup
because it changed even in the early
days they said that they that they had
no understanding of metal yeah they
started essentially as a punk band yeah
they really they were mostly just making
fun of metal yeah um but eventually they
did
i guess get a taste for metal and
started to learn how to write metal the
way it's because they didn't understand
how metal was written yeah it sounded
more like punk rock
yeah you know and then they didn't do
that but they didn't know anything about
metal yeah and they ended up like
bringing in other members later on that
were actually like really good like
metal players like once they decided hey
maybe we'll get serious and like do
because i think like the first couple
albums they did they said they kind of
like sounded like [ __ ] and they were
just kind of like bullshitty because i
think their main thing
like i said some of them were musicians
but mostly they were artists and so they
were into they wanted to do comic books
and make movies and you know [ __ ] like
that so
me the music was kind of like secondhand
so i feel like later on i think my me
and my brother had a couple of their
albums like later on i think we had scum
dogs in the universe i think we had that
one that was called hello
and um
what is i know there was a couple other
ones we had i mean they're not really
it's it's kind of like they're kind of
like fall into the same thing as like
the jenna torturers where
you know you have their albums and stuff
but it's not usually something that you
would like listen to i mean they're much
better when you go see them live rather
than just like listening to your [ __ ]
because most of their appeal is
in the live show like all the crazy [ __ ]
that they yeah although 120 days of
sodom is a good album it is yeah oh yeah
yeah i'm not saying that i'm just saying
that i think a lot of their appeal is
mostly from their performance or like
their live show rather than just their
music like a divorce from that yeah but
um we got into jen a couple years back
she was still cute yeah we saw her at uh
what show was that
combo christ
no well um
it might have been combo crazed but um
because i remember going to that brian
was playing that night
wasn't brian manowitz oh that's right he
was playing that night yeah what the
[ __ ] show was that and i don't know he
was yeah he was in one of the opening
bands yeah he's also vegan black metal
black metal chef he's a friend of ours
he's in a band
yeah yeah that's right cookbook i forgot
about that i forgot about that so yeah
he was in one of the opening bands i
still can't remember what show that was
i remember it was at uh that what the
[ __ ] is the name of that place like in
downtown
uh i don't think it's called that
anymore but uh it was called uh
firestone the fire zone yeah it was at
fire it was called firestone and we
haven't seen and i've only seen a few
shows at firestone and i remember combat
christ being one of them we saw gary
newman at firestone yeah but i don't
remember i know it wasn't the gary
newman joe
so maybe it was common christ or maybe
it was like another one
firestone was a great venue but the
problem with it was is that the owner of
[ __ ] one skinny puppy was it
might have been no no we saw skinny
puppies
no wasn't it uh we saw skinny puppy
somewhere else it wasn't um
i thought it was like i thought it was
more like um gary newman
no because brian's band wouldn't have
been opening for gary newman it was
around that same time it was though we
went to a lot of uh well was it wasn't
uh nitsureb was it
no we saw an israel up there too no we
didn't around that time yes we did well
no no no no you were with me yeah you
you might have seen that so there so
i've only seen them once and that was
back in 1990. i saw nitro up there with
with many me
yeah i was i don't think i was at that
show right yeah cause i've only seen
them one time and that was in 1990. yeah
it was them in depeche mode yeah
but uh yeah so uh if you have shutter
definitely watch the guard documentary i
mean i feel like you'll probably enjoy
it better because like i said it is like
a long time commitment because it's
pretty long so
it's like a soap opera though i mean
yeah it's like so i think you really
only have to have like maybe a passing
familiarity with guard to find it enters
entertaining yeah i don't know anything
about them i thought was funny yeah i
thought it was like really really
entertaining because just like all the
people involved and like i said i really
like
stories about just like a bunch of
weirdos who kind of form this like weird
ramshackle family yeah and you can tell
that they're all real i mean they love
doing this when i saw those were
pedograph posters all them black and
white and ballsacked and magnificent and
all these kind of weird names and those
had those characters they had that girl
in there you know what i mean i was just
like slime menstrual hymen yeah i was
like what the [ __ ] i didn't think it was
cool i read i laughed at it but i i was
just like yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was i you know what i don't think they
mentioned this in the in the documentary
but one of the things when i was reading
another thing about gwar
another thing that got them in trouble
with one of the major labels who was
kind of courting them was sly menstrual
hymen
uh she had a cut they went into the
office to like talk about terms or
whatever and she had a cod piece on and
she had like blood capsules in there so
it looked like she had her period all
over the chair and uh yeah they didn't
appreciate it
i'm like what did you expect that's kind
of their whole thing they're [ __ ]
crazy
[Laughter]
like i said i think that they
one of them said like during the course
of the interviews like that he's like
well we never really had the chance to
sell out you know what i mean i mean
well i guess they did because warner
brothers was like hey we'll put out your
album if you take that baby dick [ __ ]
song off of it but they were like no we
don't want to take that song off of it
so warner said now
they're very creative but in in in
they were idiots too kind of
especially from a business standpoint
they
just didn't know what they were doing
they didn't know how to run a business
they they weren't trained to run
businesses
well and i think it seemed like i said
that they didn't really care that much
about this like they really they were
[ __ ] cut throughout each other
[ __ ] bootlegging their own [ __ ]
merchandise and selling it out the back
you know what i mean hold on you're
selling merch the yeah it was still a
merch you know they're making up their
well he's like hey i founded the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah i mean he left but yeah yeah
and they well then we need to divide
that money up you know he was like yeah
nope
[Laughter]
yeah
um yeah oracle said uh rip nichelle
nichols yeah i just told tom that before
we started because i just saw him she
lived her full life though she's like
nearly 90. yeah i think she was 89. yeah
but yeah i just saw that one yeah you
can't expect much longer than that
uh danny rowling hey tom what was the
name of that film you were talking about
on friday where h.g wells is the main
character yeah time after time time
after time that was a david warner yeah
i love love love yeah you'll like it i
love that you like it it's so so good
yeah um malcolm mcdowell is in it too
yeah it has a good he plays hd wealth
has a good kind of fantasy adventure
fish out of water
[ __ ] feel to it
mcdowell shows up
in the 20th century in
in
1979
in san francisco and he's like he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] going on
he tries to adapt to it though he's he's
trying to chase jack the ripper yeah who
came there before him in the damn time
in his time machine that he invented so
he felt like he was back
time machine went back to where where it
was
um
he uh jack the ripper didn't want
h.g wells to know that the time machine
was stolen so he used it to go to the
future and then sent it back so it was
still there
yeah or did it come back on its own it
had no it hadn't reset it it had a key
that's right it had a key and h.g wells
was the only one that had a key so if
you went somewhere in the time machine
without the key it would come back then
the time machine would come back that's
how it was like after a time like
without you right yeah so you'd kind of
be stuck where you were right
yeah so yeah they had to like jack
ripper didn't carry he's just trying to
get the fuel well yeah he was like well
yeah i don't want to get caught i'm jack
the ripper and i think he left a date in
there
yeah it was still on the so he knew he
was still in there
so uh h.g wells knew
where jack the ripper went where he went
yeah and he didn't tell anybody really
about the time machine i think they
didn't think the time machine worked
well at the beginning
at the beginning he had like all his
little scientist friends there yeah and
he was like you guys [ __ ] i'm about
to show you something's gonna blow your
mind and he showed him the time machine
but they were like what the [ __ ] yeah
they ain't gonna where you're happy it's
made out of wood with [ __ ] to spin
i don't think it no it wasn't it kind of
was made out of wood no it kind of
looked like it kind of i if i remember
it looked kind of like the nautilus from
the [ __ ] it kind of i gotta go back
and look at it yeah it kind of looked
like
maybe you're thinking of like the other
time machine movie that was made yeah
maybe the old time after time is not
based on the time machine yeah it's
based on what if h.g wells the guy who
wrote the time machine had made a real
time machine and was also friends with
the doctor that was jack the ripper
without knowing about it right so
right and when jack the ripper gets to
the 70s man he fits right in
he's like [ __ ] this is the world that
i envisioned you know this is [ __ ] my
world now you know i'm an amateur
compared to these people you know yeah
he's looking at their savages yeah you
know it's like he's looking it down
[ __ ] films of world war ii and [ __ ]
he's just loving it you know
yeah
yeah my people there's porn
there's lots of porn and [ __ ]
prostitution and everything he just
loves it he goes around just killing
people
mango says gwar we'll be seeing them
next week anyway time after time is
classic
yeah we were we were talking about gwen
we haven't seen it a long time ago
yeah we should actually we should
actually but yeah do you have anything
else you would like to add about the
guard documentary no no and then after
that because like i said at the
beginning if you weren't here uh we
decided to make this a matinee slash
man i got sidetracker hammered last
night's club
so well if you have shutter watch the
guard documentary it's actually really
really good yeah um yeah i got hammered
at the club i haven't i couldn't even
drive back jenny had just i have not
seen you that hammered in a very very
long time and the crazy thing about it
is that we went to barbarella it's 80s
night
and they don't even have hard liquor
there no and we didn't take any i just
started slamming i just started slamming
um black velvets you know if i can um
it's 50 50 mixture against stout and and
um
cider insider
and then a bunch of those
[ __ ] bacardi mojitos in the cans
i don't know man it's looking crazy and
then
our friends in the [ __ ] club industry
[ __ ] what's his name
um
guy who just built that new bar
scotty scotty shows up with his little
trans girlfriend
she's [ __ ] with me and then
all kinds of weird [ __ ] happen and then
i [ __ ] leave
and [ __ ] back into a car and jenny's
like let me drive
and then we get home
and [ __ ]
we bought we bought some food at circle
k so i made that before [ __ ] went to
sleep
and i wake up and jenny's going
it's the [ __ ] weirdest thing but i've
never had this happen
this is [ __ ] weird this thing
happened
i was dreaming that i was taking a leak
in the bathroom
okay
i was trying to say man i got to take
come on man go you know what i mean
and jenny goes what you doing thomas is
i'm taking i'm taking leaks you said i'm
pissing i'm pissing just on the floor
and if i snap up like that i'm standing
at the foot of the bed
getting ready to piss on the damn
[ __ ]
on the bed on the bench right in front
of me and i was like what am i doing
here looking i thought that i was in the
bathroom
and i was dreaming i was sleeping
sleepwalking he sleepwalked so i go oh
[ __ ] i gotta clean this [ __ ] off
and i pulled it outside like that and
then i went in there and [ __ ] took
went to the bathroom and then [ __ ]
went back and i said where'd the piss go
i dreamt that i pissed i didn't piss
i was just standing we'll see i said
pecker in the hand
jenny looking at me at the foot of the
bed what are you doing pissing
[Laughter]
but it was sleepwalking i think it was
like three because we didn't get home
until i think we didn't go to sleep
until probably like 2 30 or 3. yeah um
because we left the bar like last call
and then we got and then we got some
sandwiches and stuff and ate those and
yeah and then like so we fell asleep i
think it was 4 or 4 30.
and i don't remember what woke me up but
i woke up and i and i turned and i saw
you had that [ __ ] danger will
robinson [ __ ] danger will robinson i
guess like it just kind of i was like
what the [ __ ] okay yeah yeah because i
don't remember hearing anything i just
was standing up to the bed trying to
take a piss and i turned like that and
yeah he was just like standing there
like at the end of the bed it was it's
kind of dark but i could see him yeah
and he was just standing there like real
estate was really creepy yeah imagine it
was i was sleeping it was really creepy
i was sleeping because you were just
standing there not moving yeah like at
the end of the day
i don't know
i was like ooh that's some like
paranormal activity [ __ ] right there did
you see like in that movie where that
girl was like standing by the bed for
like six hours it was kind of like that
i was probably and then i was thinking
later that i was just kind of like oh
man it's a good thing you didn't walk
you didn't dream that you walked around
at my side of the bench you really like
pee on my head yeah yeah but it's just
kind of like yeah i told you i have a
feeling i was standing there for a long
time maybe you were like i was like if
that was like paranormal activity ew i
was like i was so creeped out like i
turned around and like i just saw he was
just standing there not moving yeah at
the end of the bed and it was like so
creepy because it's like it's it's not
pitch black in the room it's dark but
there's like a little bit of like light
coming from the hall and for the other
stuff so you so i could see and i was
like and i was like what are you doing
and he goes pissing
and i was like are you peeing on the
floor
and it woke me up and then he like
what the [ __ ] am i doing here
i said oh [ __ ]
and i thought i had pissed yeah
but i dropped that i didn't
[ __ ]
we'll see and i told him i was like i've
had a long time where because if i cuz i
usually i mean especially now just now
that i've gotten a little bit older but
it's like nowadays um you know i always
i wake up at least once or twice like in
the middle of night because i have to
pee and then like
but what usually happens if i'm sleeping
and i think this happens to a lot of
people but if i'm sleeping and i have to
go to the bathroom like my brain will
try to wake me up by making my dream go
like hey i'm looking for a bathroom in
my dream
and what usually happens is even if i
find a bathroom in my dream there's
always some reason that i can't use it
like it's super disgusting like like the
one in um like the one in that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] movie trainspotting like
one in trainspotting or
there's somebody in there like there's
like a stalker in there or there's like
people like watching me or something and
i can't use it so that's my brain's way
of like waking me up i'm always like
paranoid that i'm gonna dream that i
find a clean bathroom and start painting
then i'm gonna wake up and i've like
peed in the bed but so far i've never
had that happen but um but yeah i have
as far as i know and you've never done
this either you've never like actually
sleepwalked
to where you thought that you were i
mean but you like i said you were very
very hammered left yeah i mean really
yeah i was sleepwalking
and i couldn't go to the bathroom anyway
i was rocked up
because that's what happens if you if
you need to go to the bathroom if you're
a guy and you're in bed you're asleep
and you got to take a leak [ __ ]
there's a there's like a safety
mechanism you'll just rock up you can't
business this is a safety bag
that's how you hold your bladder
so i was just standing there like that
but i think i was standing there for a
long time just sleeping like i said how
crazy because i was sleeping
yeah and like i said i'm pretty sure i
didn't hear anything that woke me up i
think i just like had my spidey senses
yeah we're just kind of like ooh there's
creepy [ __ ] going on right now and you
were just like standing like you weren't
looking at anything you were just kind
of like standing like that yeah and i
couldn't tell if your eyes were open or
closed i didn't know what you were doing
i was standing there
it was that
dreaming that i was going to bed
but that's yeah that's the first weird
[ __ ] that is very weird yeah but i don't
yeah when she woke me up i was very
disoriented
whoa what am i doing here what am i
doing here what i was like yeah that's
what i was just wondering and like and i
was i had two i had a bunch of different
overly overlaying [ __ ] realities
that i was in the bathroom but i was
also in the bedroom and that i was
taking a leak and where is it where'd it
go
yeah because i was sitting there going
oh no you did not just pee on the
[ __ ] rug
yeah it was where to go where are you i
was like am i gonna have to have to hit
you with the rolled up knees because a
bunch of [ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] conflicted
i didn't take a piss it just was
dreaming that i was that's good but yeah
it was like the middle of the night he's
like dragging the bench out of the
hallway i thought i was convinced it was
i was convinced that i pissed on him i
didn't
but yeah i got out there was feeling for
it
how wet is it i can't find it and i was
like i went over there to try to find it
on the floor it wasn't there
you know and then i went then i went and
took a leak which i should have known
that
yeah i didn't piss because i still had
cause you still haven't had yeah but it
would but i was so um
disoriented i i couldn't tell what the
[ __ ] was happening yeah i guess i
haven't seen you that drunk at a long
time yeah because i wasn't that drunk
though well not about not about it i
have sobered up
but i was just talking about but yeah
but you'd only been asleep for like an
hour or two without that was it yeah
because like i said that was only all
right we didn't even go to sleep i don't
think until 2 30 or three okay and that
was only like at four or four thirty
something like that man that's amazing
that you woke up
yeah and maybe i heard something but i
don't think i heard anything maybe i was
talking
maybe but i don't remember hearing
anything and i was not drunk because i
we went to the club we got there as soon
as they opened which is 9 30. i had one
of those because like i said barbarella
doesn't have hard liquor yeah and we
didn't take any and we didn't pregame
yeah so i had one of those bacardi
mojito things in a can which is what
like five percent alcohol and then so i
drank that and then like about an hour
hour and a half later i had like a white
cloth thing like a watermelon thing and
then after that so i didn't drink at all
after
10 30. like the rest of the night i just
drank water
and then so i was like
completely sober like by the time we
left and like i said we stayed till last
call which like i said was a good thing
because you were
in no shape to drive
whatsoever
you know what i mean you were absolutely
annoyed
i mean you kept you were having a good
time like you were having fun and
everything but you kept like yelling the
same thing at me
like
this happened and i was like dude you've
told me that like 15 times already yeah
and you're just like yelling at my face
and like laughing i'm like cool you
already told me that you told me that
like five seconds ago
so i don't know it was fun though it was
like there was it was a good uh crowd
last night there's a lot of good music
and i danced my butt i didn't i did not
realize that i was that trashed you were
yeah you were saying yeah because i
didn't expect to get that wasted off
those [ __ ] canned drinks that's what
i'm saying there's not even hard liquor
though
yeah i don't know how i drink that video
i don't know how many you drank i wasn't
watching like i said i know for a fact
that i drank two but then and then i
just kept drinking water
and that and i so i stopped drinking but
like wait about five or six of them but
i drank them kind of fast remember i was
[ __ ] chugging them that's right you
were chugging them because you're like
oh well they didn't have they'd only
have everything in cans right and he's
like oh i wanted
he wanted to like do the black velvet
thing or whatever the hell it's called
and he's like oh i don't have a glass to
mix them in
so he chugged
one can so he had an empty can to like
mix it up yeah right there no i said i'm
gonna go buy a
i'm gonna go buy a uh
a uh
mojito
and then i'll drink that and then i'll
open these two cans and i'll put them in
an empty mojito can
so i [ __ ] slammed that mojito and
that was like the third one
and then i got a couple more
yeah you were because we stayed till
almost closing yeah
and by that point like i said i had
stopped drinking at probably like 10 30.
and i just drank water after that and i
was dancing too and like sweating a lot
so it's like i was completely completely
sober yeah by the time we left there
says white clothes five percent yeah it
wasn't a white claw but it was kind of
like that i don't remember what brand it
was because it's kind of dark yeah the
the bacardi mojitos
i can drink them because they do it does
kind of taste like a mojito and a mojito
isn't strong anyway yeah um you know
those are pretty good yeah i mean yeah
it does taste like i don't know how many
how much alcohol is in it i don't even
know it's probably five percent those
are mostly fibers yeah bacardi is the
bread but i don't think there is any rum
in it it's probably that uh it's
probably a rum flavored uh like a malt
liquor malt liquor is probably what it
is i think that's probably what it is
yeah i'm not really sure how they make
those like i think because that's all
they have is those canned ones but some
of them are decent like um
i had one i think it was seagram's that
was like a gin and tonic
and that was pretty good it's very very
tart and like kind of sour but
genotonics are too but i so i can only
drink like one of those before i'm like
well i gotta get something else all
right uh look uh i'm cooking down there
okay oh look i'm cooking yeah
i gotta go down there and check on it
glenn little when talking about your p
situation yeah in my family that would
be an initiation you're one of us it's
okay mate here's the mop
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think i can't really
remember i don't know but yeah that's
just i've never done that before no i
don't remember you ever doing that
before never done anything like i did a
sleep walk that's the first time i've
ever sleep walked yeah i think that's
what was so [ __ ] creepy about it it's
like i looked up and i'm like oh my god
what the hell i was [ __ ] sleepwalking
what the [ __ ] was he doing what is he
doing he's just like standing there at
the head of the bed like the [ __ ]
chick in paranormal activity yeah oh my
god it was so creepy and then i for real
thought you were like peeing on the
floor and i was like really because i
was well i was already kind of mad
because
i hate what i don't like to drive yeah
and so i didn't really appreciate having
to drive home from the club because you
were just like waiting waiting to drive
but yeah like yeah after you got in the
car and like backed into another because
it didn't hurt our car or their car
because he just kind of like and i was
just like get out
i was like get out
um and i said i'll drive because i was
completely sober but see the thing about
it though is that i had to take because
i had my boots on that's why you woke up
because you were sober
yeah you sensed it i probably did yeah
you know if you were as drunk as me
you'd have just slept through it i
probably would have just been like yeah
uh danny rowling said what's tomorrow's
a haunting episode the lake club
episodes hopefully oh that's not oh
that's we got to write that one down too
give me that newspaper
the late club horror that's the one
where the western bar right no no we did
that's bobby mackey we already did that
one late club is a different one
let me write that down because we had
three other
suggestions
so i'm not really sure which one we're
gonna do yet we're gonna like decide i
mean we'll probably do all
four of the suggestions that we got like
over the next four weeks i'd imagine but
i just don't really know which one we're
gonna do first
so it'll be
whatever we'll go through yeah we'll
kind of go through and see which ones we
like all right jenny shut this [ __ ] down
i gotta get down there and get on the
[ __ ] all right but yeah so tomorrow
uh be here tomorrow we're gonna do a
haunting episode like i said it'll be
one of the four that got recommended but
i'm not really sure which one it's gonna
be yet um the show on wednesday is gonna
be about the terracotta army yeah it's
gonna be like that yeah yeah uh so yeah
so be sure to tune in for that one too
that terracotta army we're also gonna
cover that weird underground map in the
tomb right we're gonna talk about the
tube sure okay yeah cause that's just
weird also okay so thanks for dropping
by everybody and have a good
rest of your weekend and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow to talk about a
haunting bye